we're now going to show what we saw the
trailer we just relaunched Liu Kang Liu
Kang is in Mortal Kombat X brand new
character of bread and war Kombat
franchise right so we're going to start
with him and cut see how his variations
work out and I like to watch Ermac get
beat up so I'm gonna go with our max
with you yeah you're welcome
oh alright we won't prepare so early
this time yeah yeah yeah we can continue
to talk through this one yeah he's just
like a banana banter that don't cares
about Lu Kang has a kind of different
variations very different from each
other we're gonna go through those now
and we're pretty much done yeah it's not
ice cream on it
he's got some fireballs a kick ask my
forbearance we do not cross then you
will end we follow so this variation of
Lu Kang is called dragon's fire this one
is probably the one that's the most
similar to the bouquet you played in the
previous game he's got some of the
returning specialist fireball glow
fireball - fireball in the air of course
can enhance fireball and then that's
basically right become special zone and
then also still has a slight kick in
Dragons fire happens to be where his fly
can actually those two dates so if
somebody's trying to know so you can do
fly even though you're trying on the
Trulie
this variation
because of that and of course the
bicycle kick he's going to just gloss
over the budget okay Joe everyone's
freaking out yeah toss back in a
dragon's fire he gets the ability to
enhance the device pick after it hits so
that that actually gets you to hit
confirmed by sticks in the combos and on
an old bicycle kake news opponent
standing so similar like an ultimate mp3
we're after you to the bicycle kick you
were stored in a stagger state then from
there you can go with the high-low
throws and pretty much continuous
officer take a look at this throw I like
throw a while he did gain one view
universal Special Move which is the self
just a big spinning backhand when when
you block this move it's it's not safe
but it's possible I mean it's not
punishable but it is safe so you can use
it first combo like your finger pressure
on and of course it has an enhancement
which other just going for the way and
then looking of course has a lot of a
horse around
okay you see general more more tamil
heavy territory in liner my personal
first of all when you're on screen about
a lot of you know he's going to get we
have ground Campos doubts ups and
whatnot they came Tang yes dad yeah okay
gang and a little tidbit for the artbook
where's his up towards one is actually
fastest normal technical game where the
fire frame normal where you can punish
things right so what all do we have as
opposed to bang fire also to be able to
charge this fireball so you can use that
to sort of like before now it is like a
little bit of a zoning game taken
variation also thought he has the
airport loosely yeah got Twitter power
and another thing you need is variation
in some he can actually take an actually
enhance the enhanced ground fireball so
your opponent um is there you know
they're going to come in and if I was
going to hit you can enhance the
adorable enhance fireball
since its protect and enhance the
enhanced resume how we get is very yours
there's layers ways as you are as a beer
but it'll let you like it confirm into
something that's not breakable but is a
wasting then who knows um yeah yeah it's
just wasting it to either the wrongs
that you're right all right start
natural yes yes yes start opening a
batch with it bad idea I'm gonna move on
to the next variation they polish rifle
is bees Manas it's like you do this no
more let's see what they say to each
other a reprint they work one time like
a father
they're kind of like fern amis I guess
right frenemy yeah you're loaded today I
know right
that's good I had some tea before I came
in here okay I'll get you got amped up
no Liu Kang I give you no choice rated
so be it when we get here but I bet it
was a friendly probably antagonistic
though until renovations bridge
so this robbery and Liu Kang's called
plaintiff and if you notice on his on
his projectile innovations a change can
all be a variation so all predicts with
epsilon into Penta black advantage in to
manage solar the draw psychical all
three of those variations oh he still
has it enhanced or this one but it's not
too far but it's one single fireball
another thing is where this raishin gets
is the basket gets replaced with these
multi punches bicycle punches bicycle
punches okay I believe it name for the
muzzle flash tango Faisal Jimdo yeah
we're both there's another bicycle play
is this what you guys don't ask me to
name moves there's a lot of reasons this
is an example okay
nothing I do buy for your budget all
right and it also in desperation he can
activate the flame fists my Linares is
and then when he has this sign of your
opponents blocking he actually does a
lot more block dangers normal upper
punches and then like any trick to do is
do the the window fist punches when
opponents blocking all I gotta help is
she look a little on you so much here
here and it's only on block I mean it
does sound just some additional damage
on hit also it also makes its part about
to a lot more black
cool really enhances pressure guy yeah
it's awesome
and that's pretty much it for that one
yep finally next one is Gloucester we
missed the the parry so here the parry I
should just do what Cambridge looking
alright please the kid fancy always ask
for mirror match dialogue very fun oh
wait do we double fire fists I got
doulas which is probably his most unique
great variation in the outdoor world
marketplace we'll try and pull off the
parry as well good luck with that
yeah okay I'm sure I could do it I don't
go to this country illusions are petty
magic this is no illusion yeah we'll
reveal the truth then yeah I almost
talked today you'll see that cause I was
so bad
Maris and you can actually enhance the
parry read before the lens hit and do
some additional damage yeah I don't know
if I'm going to try that but I'll try it
did you know matching animal fashion
matching will not work to have apparel I
can I parry the barrel so when duelist
he can actually switch um essentially
switch stances inside of this variation
so we can go between the light dark and
when he said like he he has a different
fire ball as he normally does but you're
a little faster than the other ones so
you can see sort of zone out
and he's got great low kicks in May we
vote that Nessa
when you go into dark his fire was get
replaced with these little traveling um
like plasma warp things
and with these you can actually stop
them at you throw them up and they stay
out there and then they explode after a
certain amount of time
yes about this but they don't actually
they don't actually hit I don't have
collision on them and they're traveling
so you can stop and like leave these a
little landmines out you know all over
the screen and create all kind of like
peer pressure like you need combo
situations don't think he also gets a
like a damage charge this was well yeah
depending on the state of your damage
charge the fireballs will explode faster
so record as the no no um how much of a
lot of damage charge you have and you
can even do these combo set of black
strings singing like throw fire long
and like put pressure in your color you
have multiples out these are like
tractor tonnage these I think in our
light deals in the queue right somebody
is like a cow Moo we get a reverse
Ramona business there we go and that can
be held down and as you're holding it
you're gaining health and then when you
let go it releases and kill a little
extra burst I'm just doing an x-ray we
need to see anyone hit skroe a favorite
x-rays really cool I love it Luke hang
on Luke hang violence here we go oh I
gonna move on to our final or get do
this let's move on
you